[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa este es el
espacio de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
empezamos en sudamérica en brasil porque
después de dos años de pandemia de
coronavirus y de restricciones volvió el
carnaval de río de janeiro y hasta allí
llegó nuestro equipo en terreno y vamos
al norte del continente porque juan
orlando hernández fue extraditado a
nueva york para ser procesado por
narcotráfico el departamento de justicia
estadounidense asegura que el ex
presidente convirtió a honduras en un
narcoestado
y a pesar de que las cifras de
homicidios disminuyeron en el salvador
en medio del estado de excepción
decretado por el presidente nadie bukele
las desapariciones siguieron en aumento
nos cuenta nuestro equipo del terreno
y vamos de inmediato a brasil para
nuestra historia principal río de
janeiro celebra el regreso de los
desfiles al sambódromo suspendidos
durante dos años debido a la pandemia de
coronavirus que dejó al país como el
país más afectado de suramérica con más
de 30 millones de personas contagiadas y
más de 600.000 muertos pero ahora
gracias a la vacunación del 86% de la
población y a un descenso de nuevos
casos y fallecimientos que han bajado a
un promedio de 100 diarios vuelve la
fiesta la ciudad carioca vive cuatro
días de algarabía en un carnaval fuera
de época que pretende atraer a millares
de turistas de todo el mundo también
después de un largo periodo de ausencia
debido a las restricciones para luchar
contra el kobe 19 el informe es de
valeria sacol y
el ritmo contagioso de los tambores
retumba por fin en la avenida marqués de
sapucaí la más amada por los cariocas
la primera escuela de samba que pisa el
sambódromo tras las restricciones
impuestas por el coronavirus ostenta un
nombre muy simbólico en el último minuto
[Música]
y es una expresión de victoria de
esperanza porque el carnaval hace parte
de los cariocas
desfilar durante casi una hora en el
templo de la samba requiere toda una
logística para que los 1800 componentes
lleguen a tiempo a la concentración
la jornada de thiago comenzó a las 5 de
la mañana en un tren rumbo a su trabajo
14 hora después y sin un solo minuto de
descanso se apresura hacia el lugar más
anhelado en los últimos dos años el
sambódromo
hoy para nosotros regresa todo aquello
que nos encanta desde siempre nuestra
válvula de escape es el momento en que
soltamos toda nuestra energía es la
vuelta del carnaval en este cuerpo los
sanos se acumulan más de 50 desfiles en
el sambódromo vividos con intensidad a
lo largo de dos décadas pero cada vez es
como si fuese la primera el corazón se
dispara aquí ya empiezo a sentir las
mariposas en el estómago no veo la hora
de ponerme este disfraz y pisar la
avenida poco a poco los miembros de la
escuela de samba llegan desde varios
puntos de la ciudad algunos incluso
desde más lejos de méxico y de argentina
un mejor carnaval del mundo
son muy bienvenidos siempre siempre ya
falta menos para el desfile la
concentración es un fervor y la emoción
se palpa en el ambiente con estos
disfraces aparatosos una ayuda siempre
viene bien
estoy dando los últimos retoques para
que el traje quede perfecto
ajustes de última hora en los carros
alegóricos también son necesarios estaba
intentando resolver un problema con la
luz qué pasa si no se resuelve veremos
puntos
[Música]
y en el último minuto asombrosamente
todo queda listo parece un milagro pero
es la magia del carnaval carioca caótico
y organizado anárquico indisciplinado
explosivo y sobre todo desafiante
el expresidente de honduras juan orlando
hernández fue extraditado a eeuu por
narcotráfico un delito en el que la pena
máxima en la unión americana es la
cadena perpetua su hermano tony fue
condenado en 2021 por ese delito y a esa
pena sin embargo el ex mandatario
argumenta que es inocente hernández otro
era aliado de washington es señalado de
recibir sobornos para permitir la
operación de los cárteles con impunidad
en su país veamos el informe que
preparamos para ustedes
honduras un narcoestado eso es lo que
argumentaba eeuu mientras el
expresidente juan orlando hernández
quien apenas abandonó el poder en
febrero era extraditado hacia nueva york
según el departamento de justicia
hernández recibió dinero de cárteles del
narcotráfico a cambio de operar en
impunidad
en honduras hernández abusó de su
posición como presidente de 2014 a 2022
para operar honduras como un narcoestado
recibió miles de millones de dólares de
muchas organizaciones narcotraficantes
incluyendo del ex jefe del cártel de
sinaloa conocido como el chapo gaunas ya
para eeuu denuncia que la corrupción en
honduras habría llegado hasta la policía
el ejército y el congreso el ex
mandatario ha negado su participación en
dicho complot pero su hermano tony
hernández fue sentenciado a cadena
perpetua en la misma corte de nueva york
que ahora lo procesará incluso el ex
presidente ha afirmado que es víctima de
una venganza de los cárteles por
perseguirlos durante su administración
que la verdad
y prevalece
soy docente
es sí
o
injusta pero narcotraficante yoani
fuentes testificó durante su juicio en
la gran manzana que era intocable en
honduras gracias a las sumas de dinero
que entregó
a los cargos que anunciamos hoy
pretenden responsabilizar finalmente a
juan orlando hernández por años de
corrupción años de violencia y años de
narcotráfico alegamos en la acusación
que durante más de una década
hernández abusó de su posición en el
gobierno hondureño como presidente para
asociarse con y recibir millones de
dólares de sobornos de algunos de los
traficantes de droga más influyentes del
mundo
digamos que usó este dinero para
enriquecerse financiar su campaña
política y hacer fraude de votos que a
cambio hernández y sus cómplices
ayudaron a pasar 500.000 kilogramos de
cocaína a eeuu
encendí un aire states la extradición de
juan orlando hernández llega luego de
que la corte suprema de tegucigalpa
ratificará su decisión al rechazar el
recurso de apelación presentado por la
defensa del ex mandatario que sigue
reiterando que sólo trabajó por la en el
país centroamericano
vamos a el salvador que antes de la
llegada al poder del presidente nayib
ukelele tenía la tasa de homicidios más
alta del mundo la seguridad mejoró en
una señal de esperanza para el país que
ha convivido durante décadas con las
pandillas conocidas como maras
recientemente tras un nuevo incremento
en la inseguridad el presidente volvió a
adoptar estrictas medidas para controlar
la tasa de homicidios sin embargo aún no
ha logrado controlar la cifra de
desapariciones forzadas veamos más en el
informe de nuestro equipo en terreno
desde el 18 de septiembre no se escuchan
las voces de karen y eduardo en esta
casa que
desde el día que ellos se perdieron yo
amén que aquí todos los días ahora a
pedirle a dios misericordia por el alma
de ellos y vez buscó a sus hijos durante
tres meses y en nochebuena finalmente
encontraron sus cuerpos murieron en
manos de las poderosas pandillas
salvadoreñas las maras el principal
sospechoso ahora en prisión había
intentado en repetidas ocasiones salir
con karen lo rechazó tres veces
entonces
por ahí vino el problema ella le
contestó que porque ella no iba a andar
como un muchacho cuando viera en
pandilla
hasta fines de marzo de este año los
domicilios habían disminuido
drásticamente
sacando a el salvador de la lista de los
países más mortíferos del mundo pero las
desapariciones nunca bajaron y ya no han
muerto como antes que los dejaban ahí
tirados todos los días se desaparecen
jóvenes entonces es una forma de
asesinar pero
distinta a mí me consta de las familias
que yo conocí que no tengan problemas
como para que sus hijos los
desaparecieran
hay mucha vulnerabilidad en nuestro país
al llegar al poder en el 2019 el joven
presidente en allí buque le negoció con
los líderes de las maras de encarcelados
exigió menos asesinatos a cambio de
mejores condiciones de vida en la cárcel
el pacto secreto fue revelado por una
investigación periodística pero el
gobierno permaneció en silencio este
policía vio los efectos en primera línea
sacaron a la gente que andaba trabajando
en las ondas conflictivas
y después ya quedaron libres las
pandillas quedaron ellos haciendo lo que
ellos querían allí y ahí fue que nos
empezamos a dar cuenta de que había
gente desaparecida en la corporación
también las unidades que
que les toca tomar a las denuncias hay
veces job jan tomarle la denuncia a los
familiares que ellos quieren a como del
lugar reducir la estadística y a la
gente hay ladeada la familia pero
decidió hablar llevó el caso de sus
hijos a los medios de organizó grupos de
búsqueda sus acciones arrojaron luz
sobre cientos de casos no denunciados
aquí la gente a menudo guardaba silencio
por temor a represalias se les
levantaron muchas madres ahora se
desaparece a alguien ahora mismo esa
familia bay busca y esa familia habla y
son escuchados no existe un registro
oficial de personas desaparecidas en el
salvador pero según organismos de
derechos humanos cada día desaparecen en
promedio 4 personas
y vamos a perú que enfrenta protestas en
contra de la inflación los precios del
combustible y los fertilizantes siguen
elevándose debido a la invasión rusa a
ucrania por los bloqueos cientos de
turistas están atrapados en cusco y en
el camino que lleva a machu picchu pero
si ustedes han tratado de llegar a la
capital inca sin éxito vean el siguiente
informe que los acerca a través de una
exposición en parís
enclavada entre las nubes a una altura
de más de 2400 metros sobre el nivel del
mar machu picchu es la obra maestra de
la antigua civilización inca
fue redescubierta en 1911 por un
estadounidense que estaba haciendo
senderismo en la zona
más de 100 años después sus tesoros
están siendo desempacados en parís
prestados por lima estos artículos del
perú precolombino se exhiben en el museo
ciudad de la arquitectura y el
patrimonio
y realizamos una comprobación del
artículo antes de montarlo este control
también se realizará cuando se desmonte
y vuelva a embalar
algunas de las casi 200 piezas tienen
alrededor de 3000 años y es la primera
vez que se exhiben en francia
estos accesorios se usaron por primera
vez hace unos 2000 años un tocado en oro
que hace referencia a un héroe
mitológico y un collar de cuentas que
representa el vínculo entre el mundo de
los dioses y el mundo de los muertos
los líderes habrían usado estos atuendos
simbólicos que mostraban sus roles en la
antigua sociedad peruana que debía
asegurar el vínculo entre los dioses y
sus ancestros y yo elija un set
en estos objetos sagrados los incas
grabaron sus historias para la eternidad
también celebran el esplendor natural de
machu picchu que aún hoy es excepcional
y ahora es un área protegida
cada año machu picchu atrae a más de un
millón de visitantes pero si no puede
llegar al camino inca entonces esta
exposición en parís lo transportará a
perú y sus antiguas maravillas
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
joan y agudelo pueden ver esta emisión y
las anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom y envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas para
más información de nuestro continente
sigan viendo france24
[Música]